übermorgen ist es soweit meine damen und
herren die wahl in bayern im freistaat
und obwohl man das haben wir gelernt mit
umfragen sehr sehr vorsichtig sein muss
sieht echt mies aus für die csu
junge junge ja in manchen umfragen nur
noch 33 prozent
wie gesagt vorsicht über die hälfte der
wähler ist noch unentschlossen
sie wissen noch gar nicht ob sie am ende
grüne oder spd wählen spd der wahl gut
oder
söder und seehofer streiten trotzdem von
morgens bis abends wäre es mehr verbockt
hat
ich finde ihr habt es zusammen geschafft
hier unverhohlene drohung im
zusammenhang mit söders
raumfahrtprogramm und die kam riesig an
beim horst dabei geht es uns nicht darum
irgendwo jemand ihn auf den mond zu
schießen
wobei ich einige wüsste die
[Applaus]
seehofer bald in der tasche die
arthritis ra
kleine fettige franken wurst
angeblich angeblich planen ja teile der
csu den seehofer nach einem wahl-debakel
sogar rauszuschmeißen ja jetzt behauptet
der spiegel wirklich so ein gnadenloses
geschäft und natürlich konnte er so auf
montag so nicht stehen lassen
markus wie du gesagt hast du würdest
einige leute kennen die du auch gerne
auf den mond schießen würdest könnte ich
mir vorstellen dass der eine oder andere
des verwertet in einem humorvollen
beitrag nein
deshalb will ich alt versichern ich war
nicht gemeint meine damen und herren
gut gut dass die fahrverbote in berlin
kommen sonst kriegen wir bald alle so
meine damen und herren
aber erstmal ganz ernsthaft wie tief wie
abgrundtief muss der hass zwischen söder
und seehofer sein
alle berater sagen hört auf zu streiten
und sie können sich das ist ja schon
pathologisch zwischen den beiden des
krankhaft ernsthaft ja fast jeden tag
neue beleidigungen die hin- und
herfliegen seehofer war doch selber
gefühlte 100 jahre ministerpräsident
jetzt wo söder ministerpräsident ist
findet er aber dass der bayerische
ministerpräsident
zwar auch wichtige entscheidungen zu
fällen hat aber in erster linie eine
repräsentative aufgabe hat deshalb sage
ich immer eine der ministerpräsident ist
das schönere amt und der innenminister
ist das schwerere amt absolut für
innenminister brauchst regelrecht abitur
der ministerpräsident das kann im
prinzip auch ein gut trainierter
schimpanse ja in bayern jedenfalls nur
33 prozent in den umfragen für die csu
nur 33 in manchen dabei haut der sänger
gerade wahlgeschenke raus als gäbe es
kein morgen
das ist alles gibt aber familiengeld
baukindergeld bußgeld keine ahnung
es hilft alles nichts was ist denn da
los in bayern insgesamt totale krise
oder bei der csu beim fußball das ist
doch nicht mehr bayern freunde das ist
doch nicht mehr bayern so und damit sind
wir beim eigentlichen thema die
gesellschaft im freistaat hat sich in
den letzten jahren verändert und nur die
krachlederne csu hat es nicht gemerkt
diese nur bayern vom dorf den ihr euch
da zusammen spinnt den gibt's doch gar
nicht mehr wer in der partei ist was
wird ein slogan ja mehr bier saufen
vechta den bayern gut 1 gibt's noch
und für den macht die csu wahrscheinlich
ihre standard wahlspots an sie mal
gesehen csu wahlspots immer die gleiche
platte
bayern ist stark unsere bayern ist schön
ja alleine schön bei uns ist es scheiße
ist angekommen
es stimmt ja aber ich kann es nicht mehr
hören meine damen und herren und das
allerschlimmste ist fast alle anderen
parteien in bayern benutzen für ihre
spots exakt die gleichen bilder wir
haben uns angeguckt hier csu grüne afd
alles ein brei aus wiesen seen und natur
aber klar
damit kannst du im prinzip jeden quatsch
verkaufen
bayern ist schön grün ist einzigartig
aber wie soll man das genießen wenn es
hinten so schlimm juckt und brennt moral
salbe gegen hämorrhoiden von führenden
ministerpräsidenten
füße
funktioniert
mit schönen landschaften funktioniert
alles im gegensatz zu so dass wahlkampf
aber noch sind ja zwei tage zeit wir
schalten mal live in die bayerische
staatskanzlei in münchen zu sebastian
pufpaff der dort seit heute eine ganz
neue csu taskforce leitet die ja was
genau macht der post das kann ich ihnen
sagen welche wir arbeiten hier mit einem
500 mann team an nur einer frage wer
oder was ist schuld an der desaströsen
wahlniederlage der csu vom kommenden
sonntag
ja das ist eine sehr gute frage aber
sollte man die wahl nicht erst mal
abwarten
vielleicht wird ja gar nicht so schlimm
[Gelächter]
vielleicht wird ja super
vielleicht holt die csu die absolute
mehrheit vielleicht zieht sich horst
seehofer aus der politik zurück und baut
sich ein baumhaus im hambacher forst
ja das wäre dann der hamburger horst
o
vielleicht vielleicht vielleicht werke
von vielleicht können wir uns hier nix
kaufen ja wir brauchen jetzt
entschuldigen
jetzt also sucht weiter ihre faul ist
ich hätte einen konkreten vorschlag wie
wäre es dann mit söder quatsch söder
söder ist auch opfer ja der markus war
die perfekte marke hatte sich über
jahrzehnte ein astreines arschloch image
erarbeitet und dann kommen so zu gekokst
die hipster berater und verordnen ihm
ein soft se mit stimm söder
das glaubt doch keine sau hier wo zu dir
den zwingen kummer muss sich in eine
kita setzen als schülerlotse arbeite
also leute anfassen wie du und das
allerschlimmste uschi glas treffen
das ist doch nicht so sicher ist wie der
hcd holz der trinkt katzenbabys ja das
ist ein mann spielten kerl und nur weil
er jetzt in den umfragen bei dieser
einen minderheiten bisschen schwächelt
hier bei denen die wir heißen ihn noch
die die mit den schönen stimmen mit den
titel traum genau jetzt muss er sich
verbiegen und irgend so eine viper
scheiße labern und das hängt auch nicht
vom geschlecht ab sondern häufig auch
einfach von der person ab dem stil
es gibt ruhiger männer zaghaft der
männer schüchtern der männer so wenig es
ist so traurig sowas der höchste doch
wie dem diakon aus rosa aus kulanz ja
okay so dass berater sind schuld habe
ich verstanden wer noch ja da kommen sie
nie drauf die wahren schuldigen hat
jetzt unser ehrenvorsitzender ausgemacht
der gute alte stammelte stoiber nicht
söder oder seehofer seien schuld an
beliebtheits absturz sondern schlichtweg
der bevölkerungswandel im freistaat
genauer der zuzug von deutschen nach
bayern
ja ja ja die deutschen sind schuld wir
haben in gutem glauben deutsche in unser
schönes bayern gelassen seit 2003 fast
zwei millionen und jetzt wählen diese
undankbare besser andere parteien
von wegen islamisierung die eigentliche
gefahr ist die germanisierung bayern die
was läge da sind hessen dabei
sauerländer manche sind sogar
evangelisch laufen hier frei ricciardo
und wir können sie nicht mal abschieden
weil nrw können sich ihres
herkunftslandes bis dahin
ich verstehe den lärm im hintergrund
nicht nein ich fordere anker zentren für
bayern mit preußischen
migrationshintergrund und hier in der
task-force hier fangen wir damit an das
waren die der sachse du dir wollte am
sonntag die grünen wählen
ja aber herr pufpaff laut wikipedia
kommen sie doch aus bad honnef wie ich
bin klug hebe die horus muss jetzt doch
für türken normal und so sowohl sicher
ganz anderes patron fc st
da anhören
[Applaus]
[Musik]